[Music]
i saw a tweet recently that said quote
way too many young guys are taking life
advice from childless 40 year old men
end quote i'm a student in my early 20s
and i'm a voracious podcast listener
europod lex friedman biology interviews
neval etc i think this tweet was cynical
and off the mark but do you think people
at my stage of life should be careful
about relying too much on what they
learn from your generation
all right let's let's take a stab at
this
so i think that
people at any stage of life should be
careful about relying too much
on
any particular
single archetype or demographic or
psychographic
right so i will point out also
biology has kids naval has kids
so those two
i would accept
from the question because they're not
childless
lex i don't believe has kids
i do not currently have kids
so
it also depends on
what type of advice you are
consuming
and
are these people
practicing what they preach are they
walking the walk and not just talking
the talk so
it depends for me
highly on the type of advice
so if i'm talking to
let's say an ifs therapist i'm not going
to ask them for
say general contractor constructing
advice for a remodel that that i might
be in the middle of i'm going to
recognize
just like me just like anyone else there
are constraints and limits to the
expertise of any one person and i'm
going to look for practitioners so i
would say that
and if you are getting all of your
advice from people who fit neatly into a
handful of parameters let's just say
40 year old childless men
then i do think that is a
prompt for
pausing and
diversifying
but you know diversifying here really
just means
changing some of those variables
and i i think that is incredibly helpful
for
your intellectual health it is
incredibly helpful for
preserving a healthy level of skepticism
so you don't accidentally get
indoctrinated into the cult of
personality x and
those are my general thoughts part of
the reason i do this podcast and kept
the tim ferris show very broad in its
possible scope is i want to speak with a
very wide spectrum of folks if i only
were able to speak to business people
because this were strictly a business
and entrepreneurship show i would have
stopped doing this a long long time ago
and
i do try to follow the advice then that
i'm giving right now and
that said
i will
also
underscore that
if you are studying and taking advice or
considering advice you should certainly
consider and stress test the advice
before
implementing it
then you are ahead of a lot of people
who just don't do that at all
who are happy to regurgitate whatever
the latest news is that they've pulled
from their doom scrolling on twitter
and yell and shout on the internet so if
you are engaged in any type of
self-development you are already i would
say ahead of the curve but certainly
much like a physical diet
a spectrum of different foods
will likely cover more bases keep you
healthier
than
some type of strictly regimented
you know
monocategorical type of eating and
that's true for your information diet as
well so
i would say
that my general thoughts
are pretty pretty simple in that respect
you